anyway we receive on the rack here and
read on the reyes onward there you go el
army al Raton gracias guilty man this
past weekend I'll soon with my friend
big wave Dave b-dub d-boy big wave Dave
out there bro don't let him drown you
feel me cuz you some other people have a
name like that you know
splashy Johansson or whatever or [ __ ]
uh you know they'll have you know Lake
Jake or something like that and then
they drown so cuz they're you know they
try to live up to the name all word okay
you talking about that green a leafy
desert huh
you made some weed brownies and what
else on word I feel you LeBron feel
Armstrong you got me go oh man I'm sorry
to hear that dude I just didn't expect
you to say that just now because you in
big wave Dave boy or whatever his name
was you know you guys were just having
snacks well that's something bro that's
not nothing nothing is you know maybe
sitting sitting outside on the porch or
something or you know getting in your
car and you haven't started it yeah but
you haven't you're not looking at your
phone yet or anything you're just
sitting in their home word to say a
little bit of those brownies he left in
the morning after last night I mean I'm
sorry so yeah just feeling a little
guilty probably won't ever tell
and yeah it's just that has no to to
carry on on these for the rest of my
life Gang Gang Gang oh yeah that's a lot
when you're out there drugging your own
mother secretly through dessert that's
heavy
you know that's real real heavy and your
mother you know the lady that brought
you out of her own womb bro she sprouted
you out into the world through that
Vahine Papa and you drugging her out at
the house she can't even go to her own
icebox and get a couple of sweet treats
without you [ __ ] dousing her up hey
sis crease to Papa I mean come home
young mother who just stated you inside
of her body brother who sprouted you
from the size of nothing and who just L
just let you down that magic sweat
elevator into the world into existence
and you out there dousing her up with
them a little Cosby cakes Brooke come on
man bro you need to write your mama a
letter dude and mail it to her and tell
her what happened bro I don't think it's
the thing you say face-to-face I think
you sent her a letter and say look mom
I'm that dude you know that drugs his
mother I'm the guy who drugs his mother
through night times you know through
sweets through you know morsels through
you know dessert cuz who you know the
same way what's next you're gonna you
know slip your father a couple things on
Molly bro you're gonna put a little
percocet in yes and your sister-in-laws
pudding where does it end so I think
coming clean breath and that's it and
they'll call you big wave Dave and come
and clean Jeanne and I know your name's
not Jean but if it was it would make
great sense that evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one